[Music]
[Applause]
albert breer monday morning quarterback
set to join us a few topics to dive into
um let me start with deshawn watson the
commissioner said that they're wrapping
up the investigation then they turn it
over to their disciplinary committee are
they two separate parties where the
commissioner is not going to rule on
desean watson yeah it goes to the
disciplinary committee where they make a
recommendation to the commissioner and
the commissioner has to make the final
decision but
i mean i
every indication you get the
commissioner
sort of the way that the reason it was
done this way was because i don't know
the commissioner wants to be judge jury
and executioner anymore
um and i think this is the way that the
union wanted it too when they were
negotiating these things a couple of
years ago so
you know that's sort of where it is um
they always talk to the player almost
always talk to the player last which is
that happened last week in texas
and i think the one loose end you want
to pay attention to here now
um is there's still about a month of
discovery left and so they don't really
need to make a decision before training
camp um there's no real urgency to do it
before training camp i know some people
have sort of pointed to this weekend and
said well you know this could be the bad
news dump
i just don't know that they even though
the investigation has uh you know pretty
much wrapped up
i i don't know they would want to jump
the gun
if they don't have to at this point
because
you know just knowing that the discovery
phase is going to be over when we get to
july 30th and then july 1st they could
very easily just make their decision
with a little bit more information and a
little bit more clarity what's going to
come out in the courts over the course
the next couple of i mean maybe the next
couple of years how do you think the
commissioner factors in two grand juries
didn't decide yeah to indict him now you
have civil cases you have 22 women
um
roth
roethlisberger ezekiel elliott
um are are they going to be
sort of the blueprints here of what the
commissioner might do
in a situation like this yeah i think so
and you know one of the things to pay
attention to dan is like those two cases
zeke and and roethlisberger
um happened before there was like a
change in the way that they do these
things and that
you know back then i don't think they
minded preempting a court decision um
since then they've been a lot more
hesitant to to do these sorts of things
they've you know stubbed their toe on
numerous occasions getting ahead of the
course ray rice josh brown there are
examples of it
and so i think in this case
you know would you like to have complete
closure um on the legal process yeah you
would i think it's too high profile a
case to leave this is a loose end
through the 2022 season
so i think what you're going to see is
they likely suspend him
and i think for a significant period of
time
and i think the way this is going to be
laid out is that he was irresponsible
and put himself in these situations
whether he was guilty or not he put
himself in a position
to embarrass his team to embarrass the
league which is sort of what the verbage
was on roethlisberger back in 2010
and then i think because there's still
you know the open-ended
miss of the the legal process because
the civil you know the civil case hasn't
the civil cases haven't run their course
i think the commissioner is also going
to leave open the possibility that he
could add to the punishment if more
stuff comes out in 2023 um because again
like and i'm sure you guys have been
over this
they've come to an agreement the sides
have come to an agreement that you know
once training camp starts
they're going to sort of press pause on
the civil cases and pick it up again
march 1st
and so if there's no
closure if there's no settlement between
now and the beginning of training camp
um we're not going to have closure on
this until 2023.
help me understand that the owners had
an epiphany and now they want to kind of
uh
take inventory with daniel snyder like
like now you might want to vote on
whether you want to keep him as an owner
like he's embarrassed the shield i mean
what has he done that's positive for the
game and for that franchise that now
these owners
may decide that they don't want him in
their fraternity anymore yeah i think
you know it's
well a there's the financial part of it
which i mean there's the whole don't
mess with my money thing and all that
um and i think like if you pay attention
to the way the commissioners talked i
think you really saw a change at the
super bowl
he is very very careful roger is about
stepping on the toes of any of his
bosses and that's what the 31 owners are
right those are his bosses
um and he's careful about speaking for
them
and the super bowl
he actually detailed the process for
voting one of them out you know and i
thought like to myself when you heard
him say that and i know it didn't get a
ton of attention but when you heard him
say that there had to be people who
signed off on that you know what i mean
like there had to be people who said
we're okay with you going forward and
talking about this publicly
you know and so i think
um there has been a change in that this
one thing has led to another has led to
another
and you know i
i still don't think we're at the point
where they're going to vote him out yet
um
i think what happens with the mary jo
white investigation is going to be
pivotal to whether or not we get to that
point
but they've already sort of broken the
seal on starting to talk about it
and that's a step towards the nuclear
option
and i think they're going to be very
very careful about pressing that nuclear
button because of what it means for all
of them the precedent of taking somebody
else's team away
the possibility that snyder all of a
sudden returns fire on some of the guys
um what could happen if people are
digging through other owners trash
um but
you know i i think a lot of it's going
to sort of ride on what's in that mary
jo white report and then also like to
what level
um and i know this sounds horrible
because you know you're talking about
you know financially screwing somebody
versus some of the way worse stuff that
happened in that organization but i but
i do think part of this is going to be
to what level
was daniel snyder screwing the rest of
his partners financially talking albert
breer senior nfl reporter lead content
strategist for the monday morning
quarterback a couple other uh topics
here to touch on aaron donald's
situation
um i think he has what three years 55
million left that's right um he's
looking at these other numbers that
people are getting uh
what what do you think the future is and
i don't know what the ram salary cap is
to be able to do something new for him
but where are we headed with the rams
and aaron donald yeah i mean i think
like the aaron donald i think aaron
donald and cooper couple both get done i
do think the rams to some degree painted
themselves in a corner here and so
openly talking about how they were
willing to do it when both guys had
significant time left on their deals and
part of the issue with donald is his
deal's already sort of been mortgaged
you know there's tens of millions of
dollars
in pro-rated amounts that have been
pushed off
and so like the the way you would do
this normally is all right we're gonna
go back into the deal we'll add like two
years to the back end we'll push the
lower numbers to the back end and move
all the big money up front and so you'd
essentially be creating a new contract
on front of the on the front of the old
contract so he gets bigger money now
and can cash in and be rewarded for what
he just accomplished for the team
you know the question i think then
becomes how do you move some of that
money around that you've already pushed
off into the future and what sort of
issue that can create for you going
forward and i think that's where it
becomes complicated for the rams and
that's i think
ultimately like dan you know they've
they've been playing for now for so long
and they've used draft picks and cab
space that way for so long
and it's just interesting to look at how
like all this stuff continues to get
pushed forward into the future
and when they're actually going to have
to reckon with that remember the caps
also going to go up significantly in the
next few years the new television deals
kick into the equation and so
i think because of the amount of
money they've mortgaged on donald's deal
it's complicated i think it'll get done
um but i also wouldn't underestimate
donald's you know willingness to push
the envelope on this either he's not
there right now
he lives in the area but he's not there
right now
and
he's never shown any fear in the past of
holding out like he staged significant
holdouts when really nobody else was two
summers in a row so i also wouldn't
underestimate his willingness
to
sort of step on the team's throat to try
to get something done
if this was the patriots it feels like
the patriots would move on from aaron
donald
maybe yeah age 31 he just turned 31 yeah
i mean what you're going to pay him and
you've gotten his best work
yeah it's like albert pujols with the
cardinals you've got 10 great years and
all of a sudden you're like uh we're
good we'll move on from you so the
difference though dan to me is like
the like if we go back a decade and
you're talking about the patriots right
like the way the patriots were built in
the way the colts were built right and
both of them were very successful so
it's not that there's one right way and
what one wrong way
but the patriots emphasize balance
through their roster and so what they
built if you took a star out of it was a
little sturdier whereas like if you
remember the colts they were very
top-heavy they had like eight or nine
guys making all the money and obviously
they were really successful doing that
but you remember what happened in 2011
when peyton got hurt and then a couple
of the other guys got old the whole
thing came undone
and then they had to completely rebuild
it around andrew luck in the years to
come and so
that's the issue with the rams doing
something like that is they're sort of
built on that colts model you know where
you have and they've been again really
successful doing it
but you have a handful of guys who
you're very very reliant on who are
making all the money
and
when you take one of those pieces out
what does it mean for the rest of the
group i think that's sort of the issue
with
being
taking i guess a patriots mentality to
that now that said they've been a
they've been okay moving away from guys
like they got rid of marcus peters they
got rid of jared goff they got rid of
todd gurley so they've been willing to
do it
um
donald's just been such a big piece and
i just don't know what happens that
defense in that group if you take him
out
uh kyle shanahan says he expects jimmy
garoppolo to be traded he's just not
sure when and where
uh
okay
if you're jimmy garoppolo how do you
feel when your coach says yeah you're
going to be traded we don't know when or
where
i think you understand if you're jimmy
because this is so injury related you
know and he chose not to get surgery
after the season and that was his choice
and you know i i know a big part of it
was like he felt like
if i give this four weeks six weeks it's
gonna get stronger and maybe i can you
know deal with this non-surgically
and the juncture at which he got the
surgery made it tough for the niners to
move him because now
if you're trading for him right if
you're another team trading for him he's
got one year left on his deal
and he's coming back off of a rotator
cuff
and so you think he's going to be okay
in july but if you're only buying him
for one year and there's any sort of
uncertainty on that and you're going to
pay him 25 million dollars
that's kind of a tough sell you'd like
to see him throw first and so i think
where the niners have moved now is to
let's let trey lance have the spring
let's let jimmy rehab
let's let all these other teams have
their situations play out at quarterback
and then maybe we get to july first and
maybe jimmy can throw again at that
point and maybe jimmy can show to other
teams what he can do
and then you hope like a seattle or a
carolina comes out of the spring and
says god
our quarterback situation isn't quite
what we thought it would be so that
right now is the strategy of the niners
because of the situation that that
shoulder surgery put them in the niners
were patient before and i think it sort
of blew up in their face a little bit
like they thought like hey if we wait
for watson and we wait for
wilson and we wait for the rogers
situation to play themselves out
somebody's going to be desperate and
want a quarterback who was in the
championship game two of the last three
years then he gets the surgery and that
sort of screwed all that up
i think now being patient again
there's merit it could pay off but
there's also some risk we keep uh
tinkering with the pro bowl it's just
like putting lipstick
yeah you put lipstick on a pig i mean
it's still a pig uh
what are the possible
solutions here i guess for the lack of a
better word of what you do with some
kind of showcase you know they kept
using the term yesterday when we were in
um when we were in atlanta uh
celebration of the players um that are
voted in and i think that that's the
right way to look at it
um
i just think like
maybe the nfl has to look at something
as not a money-making event right like
maybe they could truly make it a
celebration for the players right like
maybe there's just that one thing where
you're like you know what like we're
just gonna make this good for the guys
right like we're not like and i know
like that's like diametrically opposed
the way they think but like it's just
the structure of the sport band like you
cannot play that sport like 50 and have
it be remotely entertaining you know um
so
i've heard the idea that they could play
a seven on seven game they could have a
big man challenge they could have all
this stuff he put that on tv
maybe it works i always liked the
quarterback challenge when i was a kid
that'd be fun to bring something like
that back
you have to have the players sign off on
it and i you know i mean god you and i
both remember the robert edwards story a
million years ago um so how do you do
that when you're protecting the players
but it seems like everybody's in
agreement
that the game itself doesn't work
and that it's not up to nfl standards
and if the game wasn't drawing a rating
which somehow it does still draw a
rating i think it would have been gone a
few years ago i think the guy that they
should consult on this is peyton manning
because
one thing that you hear about like the
pro bowl back when it was hawaii
in hawaii was how peyton manning turned
it into like this convention for star
players right like this is your like
elite of the elite it's like the mensa
of football meeting you know what i mean
like this is the elite of the elite and
we get to talk about issues in the
league and we're going to sit around the
pool and have a good time and all that
stuff
like i think they should enlist people
like peyton manning and say how do we
make this
like a resource for our star players how
do we make this
a good thing for our star players that
our star players want to participate in
i do think that there could be something
there
they just got to find a way to like
break that tendency to just want to turn
everything into a pot of gold because i
don't think that pot of gold is here for
the pro bowl i'll leave you with this
there's a pie to the face for one of the
danettes that hinges on your answer okay
most random pro bowl quarterback of all
time
i'm gonna give you two
steve burline
yep
and
david gerrard
steve berlin and david garrard
you haven't been asked this question
today have you who would be my most
random yeah
didn't blake bortles make it
he did but he led the nfl in you know
passing
yeah yeah um and he was a high draft
pick
see like because you only get two
there's only two answers here
david
steve burleigh
and can i come up with one that's more
random than that is what you're saying
well you don't no you have to pick
between those two oh who i have to pick
between those yeah who is a better
player no more random more pro bowl
quarterback steve burline
oh
i would say and that's not an age thing
but gerard i think gerard was like a
solid starting quarterback for a playoff
team multiple years right okay was
burling ever that no
so i my
like what i remember most about berlin
was how
he was troy aikman's replacement that
year the cowboys first made the playoffs
with the triplets right wasn't he
like he was the quarterback of the team
that went into the playoffs that year
the year before they won their first
championship 91 who replaced aikman
right yeah two games yeah and then he
was the first quarterback of the
carolina panthers too i believe
all right you just uh helped a danette
avoid a pie to the face with that answer
oh i didn't oh so no one's getting up no
no do you want to do you want to change
your i screwed everybody yeah you did
it's all about content you're the lead
content strategist at the monday morning
quarterback
well if if i had warning that like it
would be right if i answered that
question wrong i would have given you
gerard and then somebody had pie in
their face and everybody would have won
so i'm sorry i did
so disappointed albert thanks for
joining us as always all right thanks
for having me albert breer senior nfl
reporter and sometimes lead content
strategist for the monday morning
quarterback